ga calibre y gisait jean luc romero
alors jean luc romero vous avez 45 ans
vous êtes conseiller régional d'île de
france
ex secrétaire national de l'ump chargé
de la lutte contre le sida et président
fondateur des associations en est là et
élus locaux contre le sida bhl les de
chevalier de la légion d'honneur c'est
pas le plus important
ouais d'accord bien vous êtes auteur de
quatre livres et vous êtes le premier
élu au monde à avoir déclaré votre
séropositivité voilà
or vous créer un nouveau parti politique
qui s'appelle aujourd'hui autrement et
vous publié chez ram c'est un livre qui
s'appelle je n'ai jamais connu amsterdam
au printemps où vous raconter votre vie
et vos idées voilà alors dans ce parti
vous avez choisi
brigitte lahaie comme vice présidente
pacy
voilà
c'est une des vice-présidentes les
palaces là y'a plus jarvis brillante
on a une équipe de 27 personnes dont 14
membres du bureau politique et et
brigitte est une des vice-présidentes
pendant un genre moody's est un gang
bang a précisé brigitte lahaie
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous contentez de
donner des conseils sexuels aux
auditeurs de rmc info oui voilà tous les
jeunes de 14 ans déjà du boulot tu
faisais quelques questions à brigitte
lahaie l'après midi sur la rn ces infos
toi pourquoi moi bon de me voir il va
obliger de communiquer sur les
spectacles avec nos problèmes sexuels
ces salles pour le non il abandonne
maintenant j'ai eu des problèmes tour
mais bon je tranche dinos et vous êtes
quoi gérard comme problème c'était trop
rapide on peut lire une norme est trop
lourd et trop lent trop lent bien vous
avez pas peur quand même de donner une
mauvaise image du monde du porno besoin
de la politique non
il ya plus de pervers dans le porno dans
la politique il y en a plus dans la
politique ça c'est clair
ouais on risque a le plus de débouchés
dans lequel des deux métiers folk nous
coucher pour réussir
là en l'occurrence salle est difficile
de se retrouver quand même si la langue
de bois ça sert dans le porno pas du
tout alors pour former votre parti jean
luc romero vous avez quitté le bureau
dont national de l'ump parce que l'ump a
refusé d'inscrire au parlement la loi
contre l'homophobie passe et ça c'est la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
crois que c'est un ensemble c'est à la
fois la politique de l'ump sur la
toxicomanie je pense qu'ils comprennent
rien ils sont d'ailleurs tout à fait
irresponsable rcc non oui peut-être
oui ils sont totalement irresponsables
là dessus et puis on voit à l'ump les
questions de société les questions il
est lié à l'homosexualité ça peut
toujours attendre
y a pas encore eu cet été un jeune qui a
été tabassé presque à mort à marseille
voilà le il irait s'il reste dans notre
pays une espèce de hiérarchie entre les
discriminations est raciste est
antisémite c'est scandaleux être
homophobe voilà un peu parti de la
liberté de pensée alors justement cette
loi que vous souhaitez contre
l'homophobie ça consistait en quoi c'est
à dire s'est alignée ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour le racisme et
l'antisémitisme fait c'est plus je veux
dire c'est pas tellement d'avoir une loi
qui pénalise c'est de montrer qui est
une ligne rouge à ne pas franchir et
dire sale [ __ ] à longueur de temps
notamment quand vous êtes un petit gamin
qui a 11 ans qui se découvre homosexuel
qui vit dans un petit village et qui se
fait traiter tout le temps de sale [ __ ]
et qui dans ses bouquins d'histoire a
jamais de repères puisqu'on parle jamais
d'homosexualité dans les bouquins
d'histoire mais par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra plus dire bah on pourra
plus brasser la jurisprudence qu'il est
qu'il établira mais c'est vrai que je
sais pas moi c'est des insultes assez
grave c'est pas c'est pas des petites
choses
non mais quoi par exemple je sais pas
c'est pas dit mieux faire une loi
je sais pas ça le fjord va crever genre
de chasse bah oui c'est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est gentil de dire ça non
pas du tout je vous le dis pas vous mais
vous dis ça je pense pas que ça vous
plaise mais bon j'essaye de voir ce
qu'il sera possible de trouver les
en prison non mais le sexisme sera aussi
dans le bras d'une manière un peu forte
oui puisque tout mais non tu vois pas
être interdite mais en même temps je
crois que c'est que c'est moi je pensais
surtout la valeur pédagogique de cette
loi c'est de dire à un moment tout doit
être au même niveau il faut un peu
respecter les gens moi je veux dire chez
le premier aussi à dire des conneries et
à des affaires des blagues sur les [ __ ]
comme tout le monde mais en même temps
je crois qu'il y en a certaines qui sont
plus doux pour l'euro sur les [ __ ] sont
bannis du châble où placer les juges
nationaux blague
et puis les gens se laver mais non mais
je bosse il faut le savoir
bah oui c'est vrai on est né en mai chez
mme paix avec mon ami jean marie bigard
et françois rollin on est allé à
l'assemblée nationale pour parler de ça
on a été reçus et s'était jamais dit
quoi
eh ben on a dit quoi on a dit que
c'était pas bien que c'était une loi à
nos yeux liberticide et et que les
comics leurs fonctions c'est d'aller
trop loin et quand un comique va trop
loin il est sanctionné de par lui-même
d'abord du fait de ne pas être drôle et
puis d'être jetés comme ça mais ça va
pas vous toucher en fait régionaux
aujourd'hui les blagues qu'on peut les
classer en tant que dire par des lagons
version les blagues sur les juifs
on peut toujours en faire et on pourra
en faire heureusement sur les [ __ ] sur
les femmes sur tout le monde mais en
même temps il faut quand même dire à un
moment stop à certaines choses parce que
ça tue certaines blagues
alors là on rigole comme ça mais quand
on voit ce qui s'est passé avec nous
chez ça peut faire rire toujours bien là
elle est quand même dans une situation
quand même dans une situation incroyable
il ya des gens dans des pays qui sont
une minorité
un faux pas dire ce que l'immense
majorité des français et pas homophobe
mais à une espèce de minorité de gens
faibles
eh bien il faut leur dire qu'il ya des
choses qui sont pas acceptables ça parce
que c'est évident qu'ils les choses
inacceptables et ont même temps
légiférer là dessus c'est compliqué avez
vous trouvé normal parce qu'on légifère
par exemple sur le racisme et
l'antisémitisme
ce qu'est la loi gayssot l'a fait alors
pourquoi pas le faire pour les autres
sinon c'est ça aussi problème nous
sommes à ce que je demande c'est qu'il
ya un moment je veux que cette loi doma
ne disparaisse mais qu'à un moment tout
tout justement toutes ces
discriminations soient maîtres mais aux
mises au même niveau
c'est la seule chose qu'on demande et
puis après ce que j'espère qu'on en aura
plus besoin avec les jeunes générations
qui arrivent aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
aura plus besoin que c'est ce genre de
lois dans 10 ou 15 ans parce que mais il
ya toujours où il ya toujours une
minorité mais globalement ils sont
beaucoup plus ouverts que donné ma
génération que le sont les générations
au dessus donc elle va passer
comment cette loi normalement à la
rentrée la vente le premier texte au
mois d'octobre
oui ma démission a servi à quelque chose
comme un coup tout s'est accéléré non
mais vous êtes parti pour rien alors bah
non parce qu'on crée un mouvement
politique que vous avez dit
effectivement à l'ump au bureau national
j'avais l'impression d'être invité à un
dîner de cons personne ne m'écoutait qui
un jour le contre bischu et là vous
voilà bah oui c'est un peu ça sert
comment utiliser souvent avec beaucoup
de mépris d'ailleurs vous êtes très
combative déclaré pour moi le virus de
la politique est plus fort que le virus
du sida
bah j'ai pas le choix parce que ce
serait mort depuis longtemps ouais et si
ça marche pas ce parti vous engagerez
dans l'humanitaire ouais mais j'espère
que ça va marcher mais on va tout faire
avec brigitte et tous nos amis pour que
ça marche
alors c'est un nouveau parti qui est
toujours quand même dans la danse dans
la droite
alors il ya un truc est marrant avec
vous c'est que vous êtes homosexuel vous
êtes favorable à la dépénalisation des
drogues douces
vous vous affichez avec une star du x
quand comprendrez vous que vous n'êtes
pas de droite mais ça rien à voir face
et enfin vous croyez qu'il ya que les
types de gauche qui fument des pétards
sa patrie ans et puis en plus ou moins
grands pas pour christa drogue bras bon
nombre de droits
attendez vous croyez que sur le sur le
cannabis le ps est très responsable
parce que moi je propose une politique
responsable
vous pouvez pas dire aux jeunes
aujourd'hui arrête le cannabis est
dangereux si vous enfumer tous les jours
vous allez rater vos études de rater
votre boulot et éventuellement des
matchs ratés aux échecs je n'oserais je
n'oserais pas dire ça quand ils voient
leur leurs parents leurs cousins ce sans
fil est une bouteille de whisky par jour
plus je sais dans quel film the g et si
on est plein et vhc cherche un
partenaire
donc voilà on restait à voir que les
militants sont mieux coller à droite je
ne suis pas pauvre monsieur là c'est le
coup de la loi ça ça mais là c'est 5000
euros d'amendé deux ans ferme
ah ouais tu pourras montage on n'en
avait pas passer la loi à l'émission non
plus
il fait pas par désir à sanitaire pour
l'homme d'hier la morale et à gauche ça
fait longtemps qu'on sait c'est comme ça
ça va les ans quand on est homosexuel et
de droite et de gauche mais on n'a pas
de sens quand on est hétérosexuel on est
quoi bon quand on est bi bien alors on
va regarder un petit que le programme de
ce parti
en visite pour le mariage gay rien
d'original ouais normal c'est le
programme du bar comme christine boutin
voilà vous êtes pour l'adoption
évidemment d'enfants par des parents
mais surtout face à une réalité
aujourd'hui l'homoparentalité en france
il ya cent mille familles en deux cent
mille enfants qu'est ce qu'on fait de
ces gens là tout ce qui nous parle de
l'intérêt de l'enfant personnes
s'inquiètent aujourd'hui de ces deux
cent mille enfants qui vivent dans des
familles homosexuelles
pourquoi pour de s'inquiéter pour bas
parce que c'est pas facile parce que
rien n'est fait pour les aider
on pourrait les aider comme en attendait
le bas a déjà pour un statut du beau
parent etc
il ya plein de choses il ya plein de
choses à voir et puis justement quand on
fera aussi une autre éducation à l'école
quand dans l'est dans l'ue programme
d'histoire on racontera que quand même
dans les personnages historiques qui à
quelques grands personnages juste à
hydra jeune charles de gaulle allant de
change continue le programme du parti
aujourd'hui autrement donc
dépénalisation de l'euthanasie active
oui et attendez on est aussi dans une
hypocrisie en ce moment on a un train on
est en train de nous de nous présenter
une loi qui nous en fait pour les
médecins par des médecins pour les
médecins
excusez moi mais c'est notre dernière
dernières libertés
vous savez moi je suis séropo depuis
vingt ans la mort j'y pense tous les
jours et je crois que bon on a le droit
aussi décider de ses derniers instants
vous pensez que le droit de mourir
devrait être à un droit de l'homme oui
pour moi c'en est un le droit de mourir
dans la dignité oui si vous voulez
mourir la dernière seconde de la
dernière minute parce que c'est vos
convictions religieuses et tout ça il ya
aucun problème mais si c'est pas vos
convictions si vous n'avez pas envie de
vous voir dans votre lit d'hôpital
pendant des mois agoniser basse elle
doit être votre choix
c'est d'accord avec ça toi très
intelligent tout ce qui dit il est bien
son parti a eu le terreau n'hésitez
d'accord plat c'est à trouve que le
poteau pour toi
pourtant je trouve que non mais c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet sérieux et est
difficile je pense que quand ça concerne
c'est vrai que tu dois avoir le droit de
choisir pour toi même je pense que c'est
important et la dépénalisation des
drogues douces et pourquoi tu trafiques
délit d' écoute site web est c'est pas
bien alors brigitte vous avez rencontré
jean-luc il ya quatre ans lors d'un
colloque sur le sida et puis vous êtes
devenus amis quoi oui hein vous ai dîné
ensemble ça tout ça non mais dîné
ensemble
son mari et elle a eu trois facile en
fait j'ai toujours milité pour la
tolérance où j'ai toujours milité oui
pour la tolérance pour que chacun ait
le droit d'exister avec ses différences
moi je me sens je me sens pas
spécialement de droit je me sens
j'ai envie de dire au centre et dans son
cours normal alors quand il ya 25 ans
elle a raccroché les droits de fabriquer
des images 3d c'est une femme politique
est très important de temps important de
garder son imaginaire pétitionnent à
quoi il faut penser par exemple au cul
aux niches
elie
rangoon est bien la seule c'est ce qu'on
dit des barbus gérard ces fraudes au bac
oui bon il y avait dit alors ils étaient
parvenus c'est souvent des hommes qui
ont été trop longtemps dans les jupes de
leurs femmes de leur mère je suis pas
revenu très provisoirement bien c'est
pour les besoins d'un film gérard oui
c'était pour le dernier puisse à samia
chala cache un peu le goitre bien